fin de la visite de françois mitterrand
dans la région poitou charentes c'était
un peu un retour au pays pour le
président de la république qui a passé
une partie de son adolescence dans la
région d'angoulême le voyage de françois
mitterrand dans cette région aurait été
l'occasion d'un appel au rassemblement
des français tout de suite le bilan de
ces deux jours avec jean-michel mercurol
un voyage pour répondre aux attentes des
français c'est le bilan qu'on peut
dresser au terme de ces deux jours en
poitou charentes où le chef de l'état a
pu voir s'étaler sur des banderoles ici
et là la plupart des questions qui se
posent aujourd'hui concrètement dans le
pays certes il y à des entreprises en
difficulté des menaces de chômage mais
il ya aussi en france a affirmé françois
mitterrand toutes les ressources
nécessaires toutes les capacités pour
redonner ses chances à notre économie on
a donc vu pendant deux jours un
président en campagne venu pour stimuler
ses troupes pour galvaniser les énergies
les victoires moderne ne se livrent pas
sur les champs de bataille militaire
mais sur les champs de la concurrence
économique at il lancé chaque fois qu'il
l'a pu au cours de ces visites il à
souligner les réussites de tous ceux qui
ont su malgré les difficultés gagner des
batailles à l'exportation tous ceux qui
ont su s'adapter à temps aux
technologies nouvelles on a vu enfin un
président venu à la rencontre des
français très à comprendre leurs humeurs
mais déterminés à les mobiliser à les
rassembler assurant que les efforts
qu'ils fournissent et les charges qu'ils
subissent servent à préparer l'avenir
immédiat et non pas un futur éloigné si
tout n'est pas acquis at il constaté
déjà les premiers résultats commencent à
se faire sentir
je suis obstinée à ma tâche a dit encore
le chef de l'état et je suis fier d'eux
l'assumé parce que c'est difficile
voilà une grande ambition
conquérir l'avenir
maîtriser le présent est ceci au moment
où ce peut être le plus difficile
cela ne m'inquiète pas
je voulais déjà dit c'est parce que
c'est difficile
il vaut la peine de s'y appliquer et
j'aurais regretté d'être là une période
plus aisés
ici en poitou charentes le président
était chez lui parmi les siens il a été
écouté il a été applaudi reste à savoir
si son message a été compris ici mais
aussi dans le reste du pays